est-ce qu'il y a de bien c'est que tout
le monde a travaillé pratiquement sur
les sur les vignettes là en fait et donc
chacun apportait de sa personne et de ce
qui ce qui savait le mieux fait des
personnes places c'est souvent justice
initié à la bande dessinée cet événement
se tenait pour la 4e fois au château de
Buc comme professeur le dessinateur et
rock scénariste de la BD les profs qui
animait cet atelier auprès de Damien et
des 7 autres participants c'est un
milieu assez attractif c'est un lieu
créatif et ça peut aussi veiller des
passions pour certaines personnes ah ça
se passe très bien c'est un on peut dire
c'est un très bon professeur
un exercice passionnant aussi bien pour
les participants que pour l'animateur
on se rend compte quand un dans un temps
très court c'est à dire deux jours c'est
pas gros en 48 heures on arrive toujours
à produire quelque chose parce que ça
c'est la force du collectif c'est à dire
que je pense que chaque personne
individuellement peut-être aurait des
difficultés à se lancer dans dans un
scénario dans un dessin de planche de BD
mais là le fait que chacun apporte des
idées ça finit par construire quelque
chose et ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est que on est dans une sorte
d'improvisation totale notre grand
plaisir en tout cas c'est d'en faire un
festival
pédagogique ou vraiment on peut
retrouver plein plein de choses tout
autour pas que de la dédicace et c'est
vrai que depuis plusieurs années on a
ouvert des ateliers envers ce qu'on
appelle les publics empêchés cet atelier
basé sur le volontariat et co-organiser
avec le service pénitentiaire
d'insertion et de probation l'objectif
travailler la vie en société là par
exemple le groupe qu'on a on a vraiment
des personnes de grande talents je
trouve qui ont vraiment été moteur
pendant les deux jours parce que très
forte en désert finalement c'est parfois
un hasard mais voilà là c'est c'est le
cas on a des féru de BD qui reviennent
voilà donc c'est c'est plutôt
plaisanterie dans le cadre de la vente
neuvième édition du festival BD au
château de Buc le travail réalisé par
Hérock et les participants sera exposé
les 15 et 16 octobre prochain lors de
l'événement